unlike the metaphor of its title Glass
Onion has plenty of layers for viewers
to pull back and it's definitely
possible to get lost in all the twists
and turns if Benoit blanc's climactic
explanation left you still scratching
your head will make it clear the trick
in the early going of Glass Onion is
making the viewer believe somebody is
trying to kill miles Brawn miles invites
his old friends and business partners to
his Island for a vacation getaway in
which they will try to solve his pretend
murder as a part of an elaborate game
those invited include politician Claire
debella chemist Lionel Toussaint
streamer Duke Cody canceled fashion
designer Bertie J and his estranged
former business partner Cassandra Andy
Brandt then there's detective Benoit
Blanc who got an invitation but it
wasn't from Miles the famous detective
solves the murder mystery game before it
even officially begins deducing from the
numerous Clues he's already noticed that
it was birdie miles is annoyed that his
elaborate game which he has hired Gone
Girl author Jillian flintopen was ruined
but Benoit warns him that the game
itself was a big risk because it put the
idea of Miles murder in the heads of
seven people who all had reason to wish
him harm it's like putting a loaded gun
on the table and turning off the lot and
Benoit is not wrong even though he knows
more than he's letting on Andy had a
serious falling out with miles long ago
Claire and Lionel fear his new solid
hydrogen-based power source clear is too
risky birdie is being set up to take all
the blame for mistakes in her business
venture with Miles and Miles has been
sleeping with Duke's girlfriend whiskey
though Duke actually set that up himself
to get what he wanted for miles
it seems like someone has indeed made an
attempt on Miles life when do collapses
and dies after drinking from miles's
glass it also seems like Duke's murder
will become the central mystery of the
film but it's another that soon
overtakes it as the center of the story
Duke's death is merely one piece of a
much bigger puzzle as it turns out miles
wasn't the intended victim but was in
fact the killer everyone was too busy
watching birdie dance as miles has
instructed them to do to note that Miles
handed Duke his glass intentionally it
wasn't even poisoned in the drink that
killed duke it was pineapple juice to
which Duke's allergic no pineapple on
that right Duke don't dance with
pineapple Duke was a useful Pawn in
Miles attempt to get away with the other
murder he committed miles refuses to use
any communication technology Beyond fax
machines but Duke is constantly getting
news notifications on his phone it's
through Duke's constant Google Alerts
that Miles finds out that Angie's death
has been reported in the news to prevent
anyone else finding out about that news
miles kills Duke taking both his phone
and his gun
while everyone is panicking about Duke's
death all the lights in the Mansion
suddenly go out miles claims this is
something that was planned as part of
the original murder mystery game a bit
of really unfortunate timing of course
that's not true miles has in fact stolen
the idea of putting a loaded gun on the
table and turning off the lights from
Benoit as Andy and Benoit regroup
outside miles shoots her through a
nearby window when everyone else arrives
at the scene it looks as if Andy is
bleeding to death but Andy isn't
actually dead her journal was in her
chest pocket and blocked the bullet she
and Benoit quickly concoct a plan to
fake her death using some of Jeremy
renner's hot sauce as fake blood we also
soon learned that Andy isn't really Andy
either the real Andy is dead this is her
twin sister Helen one of the many twists
in Glass Onion is that Janelle Monae
actually plays two characters there's
Andy the businesswoman whose company was
stolen by Miles and then there's her
identical twin sister Helen a
schoolteacher who's been on the Island
posing as Andy the whole time the real
Andy was responsible for introducing
miles to his future friends at their
local bar the Glass Onion it was on one
of that Bar's napkins that she sketched
out the plan for the tech Empire that
would make miles famous miles wasn't
particularly intelligent himself but he
was rich and could pay smarter more
talented people to do his work for him
eventually miles self-mythologizing led
him to cut Andy out of his business
after she tells him clear is too
dangerous to use as an energy source he
wrote his own version of the napkin in
his own handwriting and Heather mutual
friends lie in court to give him all the
credit before she died Andy sent out an
email with a picture of herself holding
a red envelope threatening to use its
contents to destroy miles career miles
doesn't use email but Lionel faxed him
Andy's message with that information
miles paid Andy a surprise personal
visit nearly crashing his car into
Duke's motorcycle as he left he almost
got in an accident on his motorcycle he
was driving so fast Andy I almost got
pancaked miles poisoned Andy's drink and
stole the envelope
after finding Andy's invitation to the
party Helen hires Benoit to investigate
Andy's suspicious death Helen reasonably
suspected Foul Play Benoit has enough
Connections in the media to keep the
news of Andy's death temporarily under
wraps so nobody at the party except for
Helen Benoit and Andy's killer would
know that she was dead to find out who
that killer was Benoit suggests that
Helen impersonate her sister on miles's
island the Revelation that Helen has
been posing as Andy re-contextualizes
all her interactions with everyone on
the island and we see flashbacks to what
she's really been up to she listens in
on the other partygoers conversations to
try to identify both specific motives
and potential opportunities for them to
have committed Andy's murder much to
benoit's Chagrin she thinks of it like a
game of Clue it turns out everyone had
paid a visit to Andy's house the day of
her death and everyone had something to
gain from killing her of course the
solution is simpler than expected Helen
suspected miles of being the killer from
the start the theory Benoit dismissed
because he thought miles was 2 smart for
that once Benoit realizes miles is not
actually smart at all however everything
comes into Focus
in benoit's big monologue at the climax
of the film he explains how he's figured
out that miles is guilty of both Andy
and Duke's murders he reveals that miles
is in fact not that smart it's so dumb
ah so dumb it's brilliant no
it's just dumb as well as point out that
miles past Duke the pineapple spiked
drink and was in New York at the time of
Angie's death but what he's mostly doing
is stalling while Helen searches the
Glass Onion for the piece of evidence
she and Benoit need to prove miles is
behind it all the envelope with Andy's
napkin inside before she got shot during
the blackout Helen searched everyone's
rooms to try and find the envelope
everyone but miles's that is and it's
there that she finds the envelope in
plain sight it was the red background of
the picture frame that holds miles
forged napkin diagram behind the forgery
is an obvious hiding place for the real
thing so of course that's where it is
and to prove that the original napkin is
the real deal there's even the logo of
the now closed Glass Onion bar at the
bottom
Ben wall Blanc repeatedly makes it clear
that I'm not Batman he's a detective who
works within the legal system and is not
one to Dish out any sort of vigilante
justice himself he can find and present
the truth of what happened but he lets
the cops and the courts make the arrests
and enact any punishments unfortunately
the single piece of physical evidence
holding this case together is one that's
all too easy to destroy before the
police boats can even come close to the
island miles Burns Angie's original
napkin effectively destroying the
chances of this case holding up in court
miles once again tries to control the
narrative through lies and his friends
still aren't brave enough to truly stand
up to him once that evidence is gone
there's nothing Benoit can do
except maybe
offer you some courage that courage
comes in the form of another drink and a
sample of clear to remind her just what
her sister was trying to stop
with the authorities unable to help
Helen takes matters into her own hands
the Glass Onion is filled with tacky
glass sculptures and Furniture so it's
an easy Act of protest for Helen to just
start wrecking the place after Benoit
takes his leave the other guests feeling
guilty about betraying Andy and lying on
Miles behalf eventually join in on the
destruction Helen caps off her Symphony
of Destruction by definitively
disproving miles's claims that clear is
safe Andy and secretly clearing Lionel
new putting the untested hydrogen-based
power source on the market would lead to
new equivalents of the Hindenburg
explosion Helen puts the theory into
practice by destroying the bar cart
lighting it on fire and then throwing
the sample clear crystal Benoit handed
her into the Flames this of course sets
off an explosion that destroys the Glass
Onion all the people inside miraculously
avoid injury and manage to escape but
miles's plans for Clear are cooked
miles's most ostentatious Showcase of
wealth was displaying the original Mona
Lisa inside a sound activated security
chamber he loaded out from the Louvre
while the museum was closed due to the
covid-19 pandemic 10 years earlier when
Andy first introduced miles to the rest
of her friends miles announced his goal
was to make something that would be
talked about in the same breath as the
Mona Lisa a pretentious turn of phrase
that confuses almost everyone who hears
it and what does that mean it basically
means he wants some form of an immortal
Legacy now thanks to Helen his wish is
granted but not for the reasons he was
hoping for when Helen makes the Glass
Onion go Hindenburg all she has to do is
hit the override button on the gloss
case protecting the Mona Lisa for the
Masterpiece to burn to a crisp this
grants miles His Wish in a truly ironic
sense his fuel will be mentioned
alongside the Mona Lisa as the cause of
its destruction it also shows that
nothing is really Immortal everything is
in permanent miles was obsessed with
Legacy and now his legacy is sure to be
a complete disaster even if he isn't
punished for the murders he's committed
sonian is filled with chekhov's guns
details introduced early on in the movie
that pay off later Benoit blanc's wild
genius is that he notices everything
around him and is able to place all
those things as part of a broader
narrative but as much as Glass Onion is
a satisfying example of its genre it's
also a comedy poking light fun in it one
example of how it does so is by
introducing a character with absolutely
no relevance to the mystery whatsoever
Daryl played by Noel segan who also
played Trooper Wagner in the first
knives out and has made appearances in
all of Ryan Johnson's films Daryl is
both a red herring and comic relief he's
a stoner guest just hanging out at the
Glass Onion but he's not part of the
party and has no connection to the big
Mysteries whenever he crosses paths with
the party guests there's a comedic
awkwardness particularly when Helen
breaks into his room while searching for
the Red Envelope at the end of the movie
he and Benoit share a lighter while
sitting outside and watching the
fireworks of the Glass Onion exploding
[Music]